en ce moment laeticia hallyday ressort
de sa tanière pour assurer la promotion
du second album posthume de johnny
intitulé aphteuse on profite de cette
médiatisation pour évoquer sa nouvelle
vie et la difficulté de se réinventer et
des mires un autre homme que johnny très
difficile d'apprendre à aimer
on a l'impression qu'on peut qu'on
pourra pas aimé qu'on ne serait pas
capable d'aimer à nouveau sauf que si
tout le monde pense que la veuve du
taulier est toujours en couple avec le
restaurateur pascal ballan il n'en
serait rien l'homme aurait décidé de
rompre avec laeticia
mais selon les rumeurs laëtitia aurait
déjà retrouvé l'amour dans les bras d'un
autre homme
et ce n'est pas n'importe lequel
puisqu'il s'agirait de l'acteur et
réalisateur jalil lespert ex-compagnon
de sonia rolland une information qui
devrait être publié demain avec de
nombreuses photos dans le magazine voici
de son côté l'ami des stars bernard
montiel a confirmé la rupture avec
pascal ballan dans tpm p oui ça c'est
sûr que c'est fini avec pascal balance
est évident mais ça c'est absolument sûr
si cette relation est confirmée reste à
savoir comment laetitia va décider de
l'assumer au grand jour
[Musique]
si c'est ça je suis très content pour
laetitia parce que c'est un garçon
génial
ouais alors c'est ça c'est vrai oui
c'est vrai je confirme comme je l'avais
les soeurs vous étiez dans la chambre
non mais je vous confirme elle est avec
jalil lespert c'est un garçon formidable
qui est un nouvel acteur est chose
amusante super mais oui c'est un super
mec ça mec c'est un copain en plus pour
tout vous dire elle a même tourné le
film il saint laurent je vous le
rappelle avec pierre niney et il y avait
leur à se mettre dedans
comme quoi voyez là le métier on mélange
un peu tout le monde
alors pour vous dire ils se sont à la
première fois qu'ils sont appelés
c'était cet été à saint barth ils se
connaissaient pas et il a appelé parce
qu'il devait réaliser le biopic sur
johnny ben oui c'est un grand
réalisateur
la féerie soares actuellement sur canal
+ il est bon il est triple a fait la
série vers salade or voilà il a trahi
dans pigalle la série es-a un atypique
il a obtenu un césar du meilleur espoir
masculin pour ressourcés humaines de
limoges et du césar c'est un type
formidable moi j'ai très content je l'aï
beaucoup
bref ils se sont appelés sans se
connaître cet été à saint barth lourd ce
biopic qu'il devait réaliser sur johnny
bien sûr et je sais que déjà le disait
il à l'air sympathique il est charmant
au téléphone et en plus tous les deux
ils ont un peu le même esprit sirkis eux
ils se sont envoyés des mots très vite
des mots très doux mais très très rêveur
très dans le soleil se lève je pense à
toi
[Musique]
le soleil se couche d'or
elle nous envoyer des mots très
romantique
berne à aller mais elle envoie des moûts
romantique alors qu'elle est mais
c'était ça a commencé gentiment comme ça
il ya une espèce de grande sympathie
à peine rentré de saint barth c'est là
qu'elle a dit à pascal que c'est fini
avec lui dans mes déjà prêt mais l'avez
pas encore vu non et ceux ci s'ils se
rencontraient en arrivant à paris très
vite et pilar ils ont vu que ça traîne
un match et je vais vous dire c'est coup
de foudre l'enjeu coup de foudre ces
coups de foudre moi tout ça magnifique
et coup de foudre moi c'est pascal may
l'enquêté laetitia renoncer laetitia
était pour jeanine elle a quitté pour
jali ouais et alors et alors ils
s'envoient des mots et alors ça je vais
le dire elle a des copines pas très
sympathique l'éthicien parce que ses
copines montrent tous les mots parce que
l'éthicien on voit tout montre à toutes
ses copines les mots que lui envoient
jalil a oui oui et puis c'est des mots
moi j'adore depuis que pas très mini lui
a rendu hommage tchador ce mec
jalil
[Applaudissements]
voyons pas oui elle lie que ses photos
sur instagram depuis le mois de juin
donc effectivement ça rejoint ce que dit
bernard mais par contre elle a dit
qu'elle avait quitté soi-disant pascal
blanc parce que l'ombre de johnny me
l'aviez trop sur l'eau et la boue et la
voilà ça ne dérange pas a dit je me
demande si elle a répondu indirectement
à bernard après les révélations juste
après elle a mis une story sur instagram
où elle se recueille sur la sépulture de
johnny à saint-barth
donc est-ce que c'était pas une manière
détournée de répondre à bernard pour
dire mon lyon est toujours là même si je
suis face à ces révélations
d'accord